I'm Ella and I'm here with Layne more
you just published a book
yeah it's called how to be alone if you
want to and even if you don't and it's
basically a book for anybody who didn't
have the perfect family growing up which
I personally believe this pretty much
everybody in the world how not having
that like perfect family that we're all
told that we are supposed to have really
affects your dating life and your
friends your ability to connect with
people for the rest of your life so I
told it through the lens of my own story
of not having that family and growing up
alone pretty much the whole way holidays
are always like a really kind of
difficult time for a lot you know it
brings out like some nerd [ __ ] good to
you either you're getting prep for the
new year and you realize like the things
you didn't do that you wanted to do that
year you had your face to it's like
sometimes seeing family that you don't
want to see yeah there's like a weird
family dynamics yeah there yeah there's
weird family dynamics and it's just like
this person's always mean to me a person
doesn't talk to me and I'm sad if this
weird day pollen yeah that's like such a
time of year when you're like you're
forced to face like who is in your life
who isn't like we're all told that for
Thanksgiving you know especially about
Thanksgiving a Christmas that like this
is the time to spend with your great
family what you definitely have right
and you're like no and they're like oh
well everybody else the social media
Instagram like all these perfect and
yeah you look like the loneliest time of
year so i I've worked most holidays
because I think they knew like and she's
not going anywhere she's around and I'm
like okay I'll take the hundred dollar I
have like one great Thanksgiving I had a
lot of memorable Thanksgivings but the
one that doesn't make me cry is in a
negative way is um I had a second date
which I've heard is weird
it's awesome yeah great we didn't like
meet his family but it was like he knew
that I spend Thanksgiving on my own and
he his family was pretty close five so
he was like I'll come over after
Thanksgiving and he was like I'll bring
you something stimming food and I was
like oh no I have food allergies like
just like I didn't want to talk
about diet food allergies and he was
like oh well I'll bring you this and I
was like no that still has dairy it
doesn't doesn't matter I was just like
you know trying to be so Chile gonna try
to be that showgirl doesn't have any
food allergies you know it's all my
fault
and he was like lean just send me a list
of your food allergies and I was like
and so I said I'm the list and he like
went to multiple places to get like
that's like vegan gluten-free ice cream
and like baked goods and he got like ten
different ones on all these different
ice creams and like multiple beverages
and like in thermoses that's a good
that's pretty good it was wonderful then
he brought over this like old timey
movie and we just washed it and like ate
a lot and I just like felt amazing it
was the nicest thing sniffing I've ever
had yet I am optimistic it can be beat
so my family is pretty religious I would
say and
some of them are Catholic some of them
are like whatever other Christianity
variations there are and so they usually
start by saying this like long prayer
yeah you mean my brother have always had
a difficult time with like out ladprao
just because yeah so it's like kind of
like an odd thing like yeah like Todd
like speaking to Jesus directly if you
guys do that totally fine but imagine
like 12 year old and like nine year old
kids try to be still during yeah it's
like it's a little hard my cousin was
saying this like long prayer like dear
Jesus thank you for this and that and
like all these very very specific things
I can see my brother starting to laugh
like like that face where he's just like
trying to hold it back way I'm wearing
hold it back yeah I'm like I'm pinching
myself so yeah it's like churning it
like he starts like kicking me I could
see like my mom like getting nervous and
looking at us and then we're just like
please please and like I can't face any
I can't keep it together but
you know at these these prayers are long
they go on for yeah I think that's what
it's like a little kid patience and it's
the same thing with church giggles like
it's so serious the seriousness of it
too but like you're just like yeah
that's like good nervous laugh so we
just burst out laughing but like the
type of laughing where you're like
crying and like you can't stop yeah just
in my favorite diner cooperate so then
she would start trying to talk again and
then it would be like a couple seconds
and then you would start laughing yeah
and then we everyone had to like settle
down and it got to the point where
everyone was like pretty annoyed which I
like we just could not because I get
that it was the time to thank Jesus and
you guys could just not keep it together
I've also spent a lot of holidays at my
local park just on the swings I like to
like play around with how I could spend
it no yeah maybe this is how I want to
send it where like a mom at the park on
the swings by myself just singing 90
songs to myself and then it took me like
years to realize that sad it sounds
lonely but sometimes you need that I was
happy at the time but it's just one of
those things where it's just like yeah I
look back and I'm like haha yeah but at
the time I was just like this is what I
want to do I love swings I love parks
I love being by myself and I love
singing I've combined all of those
things that I mean I think you were just
trying to find some joy in this
sometimes dark world I really was
especially dark time of year like go to
something like childlike and fun and I
did but yeah when I walked that like
everybody got all like walk past the
park I'm like I use this when my
holidays there my friends are like oh
yeah so much of the holidays no matter
what your situation is is about like
what everybody else wants and if you're
already in pain or feeling uncomfortable
or anxious or depressed or whatever I
think the last thing you should do is
what everybody else wants I think that's
like when self-care is just like you
need that them us so it's you know I
know it can be difficult but like if you
don't feel safe going home or you don't
want to go home or like
doesn't really feel great to you this
year um don't go find something else and
like if you don't want to eat
Thanksgiving food Thanksgiving foods not
my favorite sorry but if you don't want
to eat it get pizza don't come for me
internet don't cover me I don't eat meat
I know that's what already you're just
like anything yeah exactly so it's just
like an only babies cranberry sauce is
salt like that canned cranberry sauce is
like it's is really good got a good
wiggle jello I always like my favorite
part I was like the only thing I like
but um but I'm not a big fan of it so I
feel like if you're not a big fan thing
sitting food and that's that's okay then
just like make pizza or like order pizza
or your favorite foods get your favorite
dessert if you don't really like pumpkin
pie again sorry pumpkin pie fans I feel
like there's not even a passionately
loved Thanksgiving Day yeah they love it
so much and that's totally okay one of
those people but you know what I also
agree with make it your own
yeah make it however you want I know it
if you just want to spend it with your
pets like that's how I'm spending it
this year like spending with people who
love you and make you feel loved and
safe I think is the most important thing
because so often we're spending time
with people who don't make us feel loved
or safe and there's another option you
don't have to spend time with them and
if somebody gives you crap for spending
time with somebody who doesn't make you
feel very good just don't talk to that
even more of a reason to be like no yeah
it's hard but it's true yeah it is so
and it's a journey
yeah no you're not you know what you're
not gonna just wake up and be like
alright I know what I need to do I'm
gonna do it every day you just have to
try a little bit and
things that bring you joy a following on
all the socials that's good here right
here and make sure to check out but you
feel alone and you know what tell us in
the comments about anything that you
want to say on this topic I'm so yeah
I'm so good at wrapping up a video yeah
that's it hello your story leave your
comment
how are you lonely tell us do you like
[Music]